hello erection fans Brian bonus inhere a
Lawrence limp-dick don't do that one
because it's not true
let's get all of the giant so let's have
people say because many people are in
line get it that yes well 6.4 million
men in the UK at some point or another
suffered from one or two symptoms of
erectile dysfunction it's a very it's
very anything some people go to 80% some
people always have a hundred some people
can only get 50 some people can get one
and then lose it there are many
different other people are owned those
guys they're gonna crack or one go
fantastic right another woman in front
of them or man good because anything a
people also stuff yeah people get
hard-ons more than straight people cuz
straight people all for them or women it
could be difficult tricky sometimes
so pharmacy are trying to start a
conversation about erectile dysfunction
finding the loo they're saying it's time
we talk to the reads it reads better
than where have you ever had a reptile
problem you have a problems say it again
it wasn't hard right when I was 18
I straightened a girlfriend I was I was
in love with yeah I was I really wanted
to please like a young thing she was
lovely lovely cuts been nicer living
nice she was quite pure and a beautiful
girl I like a princess and that's part
of the problem for you isn't it dirty
little Brian I was hooked on hardcore
pawn wanking yourself silly and she was
nothing like the women that I'd been
watching having sex rye and she was
lovely and the women that you were what
not expectations was skewed yeah when we
got down to it you know I was a bit
nervous as well I really wanted to make
a happy and the nerves got the better of
us performance anxiety yeah sure I mean
it was I taking a penalty at Wembley
even pally I missed a few I did
eventually try viagra and all that guy
at work he did come in clutch for me he
says no just meet I had a date that
night I was like I've got a date you
want to make sure you give her a good
time dear and I was like pretty good at
that yeah it was like da da da and you
thought you look down and expect to see
like 50 quid under his thumb yeah blue
diamond on it right what blue diamond
some people might be what what's the
shape of the the tablet right I came in
at the time I'm okay he was I take this
yeah she'll have the time of her life
Wow did she I mean I let you be the
judge of that
well
chuckles I wasn't there I tell you right
my back
looked like the inside of the well in
Silence of the lumps scratches right
Stoney I think she must have been
thinking like [__] hell is that the
kind of life I would like you laid
yourself know like she must have been
thinking this isn't this is not normal
this right it was like iron man [__] it
worked too well the point is you might
be stressful situations in your life
which are meaning that in the bedroom
you're not able to form and that just
adds another level of stress to an
already stress it's a bit of a vicious
circle ways that can break that by
having some great sex and great sex
definitely break so if anything nothing
makes me happier apart from a good meal
sometimes to go hunt and hunt yeah one
follows the other off right usually for
me life around you you do it absolutely
yeah although sometimes I don't like the
plate on her back on earth so it's great
that Lloyd's pharmacy up from or and an
open conversation and mature
conversation because it is it does feel
a little bit taboo yeah yeah and as we
normally on the Truvada youtube channel
not a lot is TV yeah we've talked about
all in here and it isn't a problem just
for all guys it's for any guy and if
you're a girl watching this and you feel
like you know you've got a fella who's
he's beat himself up or you've had a few
problems here and there maybe this could
help you know what I mean and as a woman
I guess some women might think that this
tablet is the reason he's getting a
hard-on most actually it's facilitating
him for sure
how attracted to you he really is by
alleviating all the stress and any other
anxieties having and you'll have a great
time think of all the sexual tension you
can release mmm through this many times
yeah many times if you want or just as
good as what I took and bloody hell
right so the best way to find out you
know it I click link in description down
there and once you've clicked it you go
in you fill in the online questionnaire
and then you get put through to one the
online doctors who can help you by the
way safely and securely because some
people go I'm going on a website it
might tell what other people my details
it's completely private yeah that's the
main thing a lot of people feel like is
the whole world watching this no this is
all private you're in good hands with
these guys but with the NHS experience
staff you do get a same-day prescription
if they deem you to be needing something
you might just need a chat you might
need someone who can give you some
advice if you do need the help or you do
need some medication they can give that
to you don't forget click the link in
the description below and now it's on to
true
this is genuinely one of the nicest ones
that we've done because it feels like
it's actually helping people I mean
literally nothing in my life will give
me more happiness to nor the I of
encouraged saw many of my fans have set
off great Steph really good sexist few
letters and all the experiences or not
keep in T Selfridge I mean I don't need
pictures sure l Delphine has returned to
where YouTube you know who she is for
those of you who don't remember this
girl brought the internet not long ago
right when she saw the bath water in
that to pedophiles
well and sex pests she's have legally it
was acts really amateur because
apparently that's what men like these
days that's a surprise as always even
when I was at school I still wanted the
school teacher sure you know what I mean
like what was that because each was
going Google gag a Brian yeah she had a
massive ass right I knew she saw the bus
water right this lecture or elfine
build-up right everyone bought it seems
and she created like an army of simps
who just I would like to give her money
do you think the water sort of morphed
them or something I don't know
yeah she wasn't even naked in the bath
wash you or us we're gonna cost you
that's what I mean yeah like if you're
gonna buy you one it would release the
swished around in its going sideways
vagina don't know but I mean at least
have touched it yeah we'll have soaked
up some various women cost right you're
not even getting what you're after then
now I mean let's be honest what they're
after is that so we watched her yes such
like baby is like a baby rapping
accepted I mean she's even changed the
tone of a voice to sound higher like a
child was she's acting like a kid
because she's shaking her um she didn't
like one of those blow up Ted some endo
she's in a house of horror before the
lights get turned out thank you
gobble-gobble
here's a big you sure that's her bum
yeah I think it 100%
I mean you you're a bum connoisseur you
know you love us if there's anyone who's
ever described me perfectly in one
sentence some kind of sear the chicken
kind of say all those years maybe we
could do another the bomb connoisseur
rights reviewing it the boss man's
really spice this one but again we can't
see her face I do this time it is nice
to refer it is yeah cuz when women wear
those tights I don't know what it does
it just enhances everything it's a
little trick for you out there girls if
you want to make your man enjoy you a
little more joy than long tights on
enjoy you a little more how quickly do
you think will then he came to this I'm
sure his checkbook so is that I mean by
the checkbook what can I write you a
check valve checks bones
I mean that looks really awkward didn't
you see the way she was dancing there
very little coordination she's not a
talented girl issue if she don't sing
like a child deliberately
no that makes me feel I feel really
uncomfortable watching this because I
feel like you know we wondered in some
sort of nightmare at a child's party I
really hate her for this with everything
else going on in the world how is this
happening
if this video ends with the black lives
matter slate I'll be wait for it no it
was just more advertising yeah of course
it was
good mushy pillowcases that's fantastic
more than I can say for myself well it's
funny because it's true
it's funny because it's semi semi true
it's not for the want of trying
yeah it's not an Amazon situation or at
Google yeah unfortunate on that kind of
cash book you know we get ourselves on
only funds maybe hope when the tax guys
do call though then you go a you dumb
stupid or dumb I'm not praying skinny
white lush she's actually got a pretty
good off site do you think yeah I'll
give over and that's all I'll be giving
her no money from this Jordy he already
had to grind out the other one can't
afford it anyway sir you need to be
saving that for the taxman what you
think a parents think your parents go
bail doing nowadays they she was she was
lovely Co school wasn't she bail she's
she's interning I was cold it was the
only only band so something like that
yeah yeah on the one hand and now I've
seen this I can give my conclusion okay
right I've seen the Baris in the painted
ass you've seen the peanut butter
problem when the chicks are pulled up on
the one hand we all know what she is
what she's doing and if she's smart she
could transition this into being like a
legit youtuber what if she's small I
don't know if I have knowing were lucky
the problem right she needs to change
that yeah when the stunts fail for a lot
of youtubers we see in the ones who are
known for making big stunts they haven't
got enough personality the bucket of the
hobby a career afterwards right that's
where she's either gonna win or lose
long-term should we look at a YouTube
channel before this and just sort of
open it up hello this is my friend mr.
skeleton and today we're going to turn
them into Belle Delphine
no be cool if she just out of nowhere
started acting like a grown ass a woman
eventually just did a 180 and was just
like the Amish is a normal girl she can
ATVs a video yeah I was just taking the
money and running all the guys are gone
no one's interested anymore people are
just going he hasn't really depends on
what side of the phones who sit on why
are you trying to defend bail no fee I
feel a little bit like you have a
very low-key sexual attraction towards a
woman no I mean she's got a no sauce
you've seen her but man now you're a
little bit into it that is literally it
got you there because you can't reply it
is an eyesore sighs yeah she's got a
nice sauce however she's going down a
road right now as a1 of [__] content
right good okay right - ate it this has
got a shelf life of what a few more
months maximum he's already losing
interest look he's not even done as well
in this video if this was open Paul we'd
be absolutely slamming him think of it
this way it's Logan Paul acted like this
we'd be going what the [__] yeah I
wouldn't want to see the law and Paul
shaking his ass like I don't know I kind
of I'm low-key into it you know who's
with slim yeah I did a bit more you want
more of a Mike yeah I think most of it
juice makes a bit juicy definitely yeah
the girls got a chance to bounce off of
this and create a career for ourselves
and instead she's just bossing herself
into a corner of being that [__] I'm
sorry I just don't give a [__] right now
I genuinely do I know that a lot of
men's dicks probably give a [__] about
this but I just do it's a nice house but
there's no sauces everywhere she was
obviously taking off 6:9 sure six nines
got that new video with some more bum
shaking yeah Nicki Minaj has got our
tits out for Nori's I want to know what
your opinion is on Nicki Minaj's boobs
what
[Music]
it's not a million miles off what we've
just witnessed Belle Delphine but it's
two tones low but it's much bigger isn't
it I mean that's the point he's got some
titties honor does it bother you they're
not real they're not real I know a lot
of people critique six lines of music
it's it's for a certain crowd it's a
certain type of vibe it's kind of night
out sort of all isn't it this is bad
this is a massive step down food you
know the cities just formed listen this
is music that when you know when you
enter a club in Miami in a TV show they
just need generic background music and
he's going I'm looking for a girl I
don't know where I can find her and
that's the background music in this I
maintain is even in goober
it had like real energy to it this is
just give it a chance he was just used
to giving Belle Delphine more of a
chance than you given 6-9 Natsu the loss
on that one by nose well you're gonna
see an ass in this one in just a second
give him a chance
[Music]
would you like the energy I don't really
care about the rest I like that she can
hang out with guys and be naked and
sexual and cool and like have gangster
raps and be sound really hard and stuff
and empower women but yeah I know I know
I mean I mean it's one of those things
that look she looks good in a music
video but if you were actually about to
have sex with her you'd be like I mean
it's also cartoon like she doesn't look
like a real person
yeah so you'll be going sorry this is
these are a joke I wouldn't mourn about
them but we'll just be a bit wouldn't
you it would be a bit I would enjoy them
right but then the next day he come to
me and you go you would never guess what
Nicki Minaj's Tesla she's exaggerated
everything you can never look at Nicki
Minaj and go can we have a natural night
she's dolled up all day every year and I
bet actually underneath all of this
makeup she's lovely person isn't she
like me Drake and jay-z all those guys
who used to be with me but then they had
a big falling out didn't there you can't
trust people like this now we used to
friends but not anymore what looks names
thrown me under the bus or Russia
game don't want try to know certain
stuff right and I might expose the whole
rap game right now cuz I got that imma
start off we meet me right so Meek Mill
has been calling out 6/9
for being a snitch which everyone knows
he is on six things now got something
that was sleeve from do you imagine 690
Nicki Minaj sitting on set and him going
to meet Mill's having a go at me for
bloody snitching and she goes oh well
you need to go over there take a look at
what he's been saying with her over
there you see on you see I'm saying yeah
mm-hm
and then excuse further than the
information thanks for that me mix on
the other anger yeah story
Desiree Perez is a rock nation executive
that works with Meek Mill this is
Desiree Perez this is Meek Mill
this is Desiree Perez this is Meek Mill
oh you repeat that one more just to be
absolutely clear who's who
this is Desiree Perez this is Meek Mill
right okay even then he starts it this
is AA guy does this if you watch him
live you'd think this was a nice sure
he's so mad you think this was an act
Desiree Perez became a cooperating
witness for the DEA in the 1990s after
her 1994 arrest for possession of 35
kilos of cocaine Perez struck a deal
with the feds agreeing to wear a hidden
wire to record her meetings with major
cocaine traffickers the cartels so the
poisonous meat mills management were one
of the biggest snitches in in stitches
these guys snitched on the snitches meat
Mills we having to go at six nine for
snitching when his organization have one
of the biggest snitches going hypocrisy
like it absolutely is I like that he's
called him out for that I have why can
we still get on
he really does use silence well I mean
to be fair I wish she'd do that more any
songs Meek Mill you can't pick pick and
choose who you want to call rat you
can't say this is fake this is on public
information this was on the New York
this is on public information we all
know if it's on public information
public information cob if you want these
clear on that on the New York Times what
are you gonna say no I didn't know I'd
you know so you know he's better at this
than he is at music he should ever show
he accuses people of things just [__]
the music off
no you you know ever since Nicky left
you you are a nobody that's not true
that's not true it's actually I've seen
some of his freestyle since Nicky left
he's still fire but people don't care as
much as what you say maybe it's cuz he's
not [__] Nicki Minaj anymore that's
probably uh something to do with it yeah
having a queen alongside you will help
I don't need Drake so I could have a
platinum singing I don't need Drake cuz
after Drake wheels back to back you went
under you Chuck you you became a you
became what Luther King what activist I
think it means dead dead if Martin
Luther King is a symbol for anything
probably it's no death mmm say JFK is
really you've not picked it up nicely
this week
yeah of all times yeah never of
celebrities been so tone-deaf and that's
all from 6-9 I mean he's always giving
us sort of things to talk about and
nuggets yeah yeah him about they'll feel
the same they're just fighting a way to
get themselves relevant funny colored
hair ass shaking you don't wanna be near
him to change clothes no and jump back
in time yes that would be fantastic
one yeah the thing is we're not done the
animation the other side so qu any
suggestions hope how should we switch
from the future to the past so the
biggest fight in British boxing history
has been made Tyson Fury versus Anthony
Joshua was set for 2021 he announced
himself on a little video which he has
normally did topless on Twitter just
after getting off the phone with Daniel
King um he's just informed me the
biggest fight in British boxing history
has just been agreed I'm just gonna copy
and paste the name from the tweet and
then I'm just gonna government urge to
pressure UAE to reject crime boss Daniel
Conahan I can't believe it lords this is
unprecedented I think before this I'd
never heard of any form of badge
happening around organized violence I
think this might be the true news where
we finally go too far I just want to say
we're really glad you got the fight done
Daniel yeah all your hard work we do
appreciate you to be honest I do
actually think that is the line that
most people go for so we've watched a
little bit of coverage of this this
morning and most people just going yeah
I mean from what I can tell from all the
research he's a man of his word right
right okay
you know when you say Vladimir Putin's a
man of his word I'd have to talk about
the other stuff but they go I shook his
hand in the deal was done the guy
apparently was involved in the creation
of Tyson Fury's management company mtk
so he's a legitimate businessman for all
we know this is hogwash
so this announcement seems a bit bizarre
because you've really got nothing agreed
yeah both fighters have to fight a few
people before they can even think about
fighting each other music and pulav are
waiting for AJ you've got white and wild
up waiting for Furies so how can they
come out and say there's a fight agreed
it's definitely happening is [__] I
mean it just is [__] the only thing
that you could have done is potentially
agreed a split which can be done on a
phone call general I mean so why they're
making all this noise right now in this
moment with all these names specifically
mentioning this guy continuously over
and over again it's bizarre I've never
seen anyone thank this much in boxing
especially someone who really was kind
of unknown to me and stream maybe
they're trying to build this guy up as
their own Neddy hood maybe they're
trying to move into a legitimate
businessman space he was a founder of
mtk maybe they're trying to clean things
yeah absolutely I mean let's just go to
Wikipedia and see what it says about
Daniel's father hear it now Daniel's
father was actually a lovely dairy farm
manager now this family comes from a
clear background of dairy and farming in
Ireland nothing more to Christie the
dapper Don Kenna Hahn who was born in
1958 and in is an Irish drug - it says
here on Wikipedia that he is a drug
dealer for ecstasy and heroin smuggling
that would refer you to be fair to him
also did the milk to refer to dog love
stealing the white stuff because it's
milk comes out creamy but to refer to a
ton you know your dad as my dog could
have convictions you can be a good
healthy clean living service absolutely
and it's not as if the Irish parliament
or any of the Irish newspapers haven't
pointed out other questionable global
links - well the ologies all over the
world and I've never even been to the
guys what no convictions Lords no
convictions you've never been able to
pin anything on me he shouted he's never
been arrested
absolutely never even been arrested for
it because they couldn't find the links
because there are no links so innocent
man kin has been named in court as part
of a global drugs cartel you probably
have to crack a few eggs in the
so sure although I feel that in this
case the eggs are skulls premiums I just
want to say well don't forget in the
deal done done the month and welcome to
our new overlord
Daniel killer Matt Ken Han so I for one
I'm looking forward to the fight and
can't wait to do a knockout for it if
I'm still alive
back to you Tyson Fury just just doing
good just in the battle using his money
you're not i mean people tarnish him
look at what he's doing for the people
my chefs have that accent as she's
northern is interested paris doesn't get
jealous I love you Tyson why would Paris
get jealous he's a coach Tyson yeah got
to keep a hold of us Big Lots yes I was
drinkin sweetie for ages and then I
start your work one morning I've not
eaten for ten weeks
she started boxing training well yeah
there's a lot of physical exercise on
Instagram live some people just don't
feel it they can go at the gym and
obviously Boris's shut them off so she's
doing our workouts she said I'm gonna
quit drinkin fantastic that's what we
want we want more positivity like that
that's praying
well done Tyson yeah setting a good
example everyone thinks that this sort
of stuff is a bit corny it's a very I
decided to change my life by doing
exercise but it actually works so if
you're feeling a bit [__] at home just
get up and do it
get up with Tyson in the morning you'd
love to do that so wake up with Tyson
theory it would be weird wouldn't it
just randomly it would be very unusual
for me to wake up next mm hearing ages
also been used on his platform for good
I mean definitely different level of
good but still good we can no longer
from today onwards be proud we can no
longer sit back and remain silent on the
senseless unlawful killing two skinny
KKK members it's a joke what a pop of
the chump do you sadly yeah in that he
goes come on that's one thing I'd love
to see if the KKK do think they're so
bloody strong and I would love to see
continuously just one off the others
rolling in the ring
Antony Joshua BIOS fighting bang bang
bang I'm gonna be rule of you about gang
culture I'm down to right hundred
percent but we have to realize it's done
don't trust me you know a lot of these
these young lads in a hard man there's
no one harder than [__] age
and he's saying it's [__] me don't
get wrapped up in it yeah Frank Mexicans
too it's great that he's doing that and
I hope he continues to go down that road
because Muhammad Ali was like a boxer
who used his fame for change and really
it's quite shocking how little that's
happened like you got Mayweather and
people like that I mean I know Mia when
I was hardly a politician yeah he's
hardly Muhammad Ali or Malcolm X crazy
but but and to be fair though I mean you
know he got involved with the George fry
funeral and paid for some of that but at
the same time I just think there needs
to be more people in sport using their
platform for good I agree see what
Marcus Rushford did yes three million
meals amazing what a guy and he says he
will not stop until no child goes hungry
I've always been a fan of Rushford says
he burst under the sea yeah when he
improves his finishing he will be the
old country but in all seriousness what
a guy and now for BG as we like the
column morris johnson Bojo little beige
a low joe last monday we relaxed the
rules on meeting outdoors so that groups
of 10,000 he's quite angry about that
10,000 was that was I don't think that
was what he realized the rules to nobody
well sure it was 10,000 Boris after six
could gather provided they are socially
distant six now only no one no one
listened funny old thing it's as if the
government have got little of the
respect from the population funny how
having you're a hard man do what the
[__] you want to admit that happens
funny that yeah but there are too many
people still too many people
particularly those who live by
themselves who are lonely and struggling
with being unable to see friends and
family or is this dawning on them three
[__] monster - it's a cry for help for
us we get it you are lonely you're on
your own and your girlfriend has
essentially left you because you aren't
a man that you said you would be it's
okay we are your support system
imagine him heaving himself on top of
you and then he goes all done yes as a
pleasurable feeling running from my
crotch Clapton Johnson's flight without
a license and as hard as the statue of
Winston from this weekend we will allow
single adult households adults living
alone or single parents with chill
under 18 to form a support bubble with
one other household spunk bubble this is
all about sex in case you didn't work
that out the fact that he said single
parents or single people living alone
can now meet up with one other person
and they don't have to be socially
distant you're just a lot of shark now
that's really really soon I think that's
what people with minds that only think
about sex are saying there's a lot of
other practicality in that case y con
people who live together couples who
live together gorn me another person why
is it just for single people because
they need a suge meaning they can spend
time together inside each other's homes
and do not need to stay two meters apart
because sometimes difficult to make
semen travel that far okay very exciting
knowledge yeah you stroke it long enough
we will allow outdoor attractions where
people can stay in their cars such as
Safari parks and drive in cinemas the
drive-in cinema a hark back to the 1950s
in Britain where we could all drive into
a cinema with our own boxes of popcorn
light up a cigarette and just smoke in
the car with our loved ones got one guy
who owns a drive-in cinema yeah for me
he's talking about House Doris open the
gates I love the fact that the people
who are shielding the people who are
sort of gravely ill and worrying yeah
well we'll get you next week yeah but
the one guy who owns a drive-in cinema
your priority sorted he's all priority
we thought about you and the zoo's I'm
very grateful to the zoo industry as we
all are when did we think these people
get a mentioned the zoo industry it's
been quietly sitting back watching for a
moment because why alerts because
they've observed the lockdown and they
didn't release all the animals out into
the streets gangster if you did want to
make sure lockdown was observed probably
could've done were doing that in Russia
know if African lions were wander in
London they were wandering the streets
I'd probably be less likely to think do
I need to go for another trip to
Sainsbury's
yeah [__] I forgot that [__] the Lions
you think with the state of this fella
and be more concerned about the
barbershops
or the gyms yeah this is the thing this
saw many of these barbershops and gyms I
would have business right now people who
you know probably struggling yeah not
important forget them because there's a
roof on the building otherwise you can
go to the zoo no problem fine going up a
little look
yeah but if he flings his [__] at you I
select two weeks [__] the gyms [__] the
barbershops because there doesn't matter
that we're all getting fat off as
ironically not good for the fight in the
coronavirus as Boris phoned oh yeah a
little fatty toward mine I can see that
I felt the same way you ain't a fatty
toad Robin I was on the [__] plump
side right salon hence why I won the gym
star burns that includes keeping indoor
areas such as reptile houses closed
oh that's the royal family [__] yeah
peaceful peaceful Britain where the
police have got perfect control over the
streets and the people love every
officer she was badly injured that
caught my opponent Lee perforated along
or some [__] like that I seen a picture
of her out on the floor and she's as I
like she was done she leant into the
lamppost of Italy and made it worse
what would you have done well jumped off
the horse for a start well she knew all
along you better off it yeah I mean
right here's the horse duck didn't think
the horse does what the [__] he wants
but yeah well he did is just lucky you
didn't turn it on to decided to come
back yeah over apparently horses a train
not trample people in the police they're
just not trained about the lamppost
this is why you should always carry a
small instrument with you wherever you
go
[Music]
magnifique
you got a mitt the way that the French
protest is [__] brilliant they finish
a shout and they go encore encore and
then when he does it they're like
magnifique [__] beautiful chica I
love this because I'm sure the pretty
sure the stormtroopers thought they were
doing a pretty good job just looking
after yeah the police went through and
they went hold on
are we the bad guys it would have made
some of them think that sighs now a lot
of statues coming into question because
of the people they depict a lot of
people now saying this guy was a slave
trader this guy did something wrong here
we need take the statues down this crowd
was in Bristol I think this was kind of
one of the first tear downs this was at
Elba Colston big slave trader he was he
known for anything else I mean I'm
assuming there's a reason why we have a
statue but other than even been prolific
it slave trader do you want to go epic
Costner Wikipedia we can find out let's
find out a little bit more about this
guy he was basically an English merchant
philanthropist and Tory well there you
go Tory Member of Parliament who became
involved in Atlantic slave trade he
became involved
I could give two shits about you start
use so you don't mind this no not at all
but I do think history is interesting
unimportant I don't think that there
should be potentially in the middle of a
town like this because it kind of holds
them up as if there's something good
pride a place it's like when you've got
your picture on your grandma's
mantelpiece you know you know that
you're her favorite grandson because
she's got your fantasies but maybe we'll
just put do it like we do with the other
grandkids and put him on the wall
somewhere I'm thinking maybe pop these
in a museum somewhere and be like these
were bad people slave traders etc but
this existed this is this is what
happened but I totally I'm cool with
people doing this you know yeah it's
it's public expression why do you hide
it in the river than Lena they they put
it in the river
and then the next day there were some
images of people trying to as you say
wait back out what happened to this
struggle well originally it wasn't the
local council that tried to get it back
out it was people who trade in scrap
metal over the Troy basically scrap it
and the council when will be probably
taking that and they weren't the effort
but weirdly
we can rush to the aid of a statue
within minutes how was this all
happening and I can't get a [__]
haircut yeah this is Mendel this
restaurant just wall looks like that I
can't go it's more important that I get
to the gym if I'm honest way I want to
get some bed
Shannon I can't bench press but if I
wanted to rip a [__] start you down I
might just I may just do that was my
work oh right I can't find that anyway
no start you is not far away from he's
not she's not a slave trader let's just
no I'm just saying I need a workout to
be fair I love everybody I would say
well there's a Winston Churchill
actually he's a little bit questionable
at the moment of it I've just realized
Tyson's been defending that remember
taste of fury yeah he's had a good few
days that's me he's been busy you want
to look at that tweet RRP hashtag
world's greatest leader clearly hasn't
come into contact with Steven Gerrard
down the years Boris Johnson grow a pair
do not let anyone desecrate our great
leaders monument a hashtag I love you
England he probably doesn't realize some
of the things that you've been saying
about Churchill it's fair to say
Churchill was as were most people in
that time and I think here's the thing
look back and your great grandma a great
granddad probably agree with Churchill
because that was the prevailing thought
of that year it's difficult isn't it
it's like there's a difference between
outdated views and people who were
ill-informed and then hate-filled
horrible people I think it depends on
where the line is drawn I do think
Churchill had a little bit of hate in
his heart when he once said I hate
Indians this is a direct quote I hate
Indians they're beastly people with a
beastly religion he also referred to
Palestinians as barbaric hordes who act
little but camel dung Robert the thing
is though yes although he looks a bit
like you're on everyone's got a few
skeletons in the closet the way we're
gonna improve this or madam children
it's a no statue though that's what sort
of annoys me a little bit is actually it
is a good statue the guy who made it
must be pissed off I tell you who is
personal Tommy Robinson oh he is he's
not having the best day Tommy you met
him at a bar at an event once and he was
just there and I was a spoke to him did
you agree with your views at the time no
I I said our people have been asking me
to come on the podcast I was a bit of an
issue with the sponsors like you know
because obviously have you on the
podcast sponsors are probably pull out
so it's not that I wouldn't say don't
have a conversation with a guy watch not
the right time
yeah you then spun that what are on his
Instagram true Jordi's too scared to
have me on doesn't sound like my little
Stephen so I lied there was far missed
and I had all of them DM and me saying
oh you're scared are you I was like well
of me a
Tommy Robinson makes you wonder what
else he said that might not be true no
that was it when I was on the receiving
end of an actual lie that he told it was
audience purely to make himself look
bigger and better discrediting me making
me look a certain way just to build
himself up it I thought if he just said
it was audience yeah true Geordi he said
you would have had a chat with me but
his sponsors would have made that an
issue so therefore he can't do it that
would've been fine fine that would be an
absolute fine absolutely fine instead of
just saying the truth you had to make it
out like oh I'm too hot for TV you know
it made me feel a little bit like why
you've beaten this out like something it
isn't what it made me realize is he
likes to come across as a man of
principle and that he's doing this
completely out of a necessity to be to
be a force of change and in reality his
eagle is 1 million percent a part of
this because just to build himself up he
threw me under the bus for no reason I
heard there was about 10 lads guarding
that Churchill Memorial at Churchill
statue I need for the police to come and
remove that probably move throughout the
word because thousands of people were
gonna beat the [__] out of them if it
didn't if anything the police were
protecting the British people what was
going on in the police who were meant to
be there to protect statues that is
exactly what we said when we sounds were
police and serve the Sutton
I wouldn't had what the rest of that
sentence was I just see now how many
more of you have seen I've seen
someone's put up for a unity
demonstration in London next salad you
know what if you're a lad well you call
yourself a lad and you're a football
that and you go to football and you you
give a [__] at all about our country our
history our culture or identity or
differences ring a bell a football make
sure you're not gay you see they've just
pulled down some statue from 1700 300
years old they've they've attacked an
old man I really never thought that Tom
you cared so much about ladies that you
yeah this has come out of nowhere we all
know when you put a statue up you never
touch it again the statue stays forever
all right we've got the statue don't
even talk about it our opinions but then
yes leave the opinions forever always
the same the opinions will never change
who gives a [__] voice about what a man
done is part bridge history really it's
a very dark part of British history
where we did some really bad things in
the modern day all crimes probably don't
want to celebrate we need to keep that
statue up there why so that we don't
know what it stands for I kept
absolutely about keeping this statue I
don't think should stand for anything
what's your logic what are you gonna
start with NYX Churchill said this
that's what next if this isn't stopped
next Saturday they'll be ripping
Churchill to statute down you know what
you scumbag protesters you want to post
statue down start with a BBC it's a pain
of all who created a sculpture of a
naked boy being held by a man will do
that one as well if it is a PDF a statue
I'll take that one down - wanna know one
on one under the other exactly a chill
Winston's over here oh here's the
Pinot's I'll take them all down good
idea if anything Tommy Robins helped in
the left wing here he's just listing the
people with is that really the shop in
the soul literally gone or should we
talk about Churchill's comments very
good Tommy thank you everyone we'll
leave that one up there for now we'll
just put the racism below Tommy would
take it down we went good idea tell me
you know that Andy Joshua you've
anything to say about this she got
anything to say about what it done to
Churchill statue or you think he's a
racist as well do you what about Little
Mix you Darren Young we've all been
waiting to our little mixer saying when
I saw these protests I went I cannot
wait for a little gangster waiting what
would little miss it that was the first
thing I keep in my head just want to go
back the fact that he calls out Anthony
Joshua I remember once a man who's the
same size as Anthony Joshua without when
I met Tommy was there his name was shun
and the cannon Briggs done and six foot
four moving 20 stone yeah same size AJ
Shannon recognized Tommy Robinson don't
know you don't know there's very few
humans on this earth more frightening
than Shannon Briggs right actually
because you're not quite sure that the
operator of that machinery is fully in
control absolutely
it's like being around a lion you just
hope it's in a good mood yeah you know
Tommy suddenly everyone in the room
becomes Joe exotic was the can embrace
walks in the shadow randomly recognizes
Tommy look I hate Muslims brilliant no
Tommy had this look on his face that's
exactly what literally that was the that
was it well normally in Tommy's mind he
goes foreign shunning like what Tommy
his little head his little peanut sized
head in between his arms and give him a
little bit of like a hug he was like I
don't mind I don't you you Forney you
finally Tommy disappeared into the grip
of this just bear yet this grizzly bear
is a human unsaid
not a thing I've in fact I've never seen
any
and so worried in my entire [__] life
so while he's given it the big one on
here FS believe as I've seen when he's
been in the presence of a heavyweight
boxer it would be like that look were
you doing that define do your bats crazy
in his country's [__] to be on
unrecognizable the Labour Party
supported that today the Labour PI how
[__] weak Tommy Robinson outraged by
people having a protest in London Tommy
what should we do preachers and London
protests in London absolutes
how many people are going to London next
are they every single man should be in
London next Saturday Here I am in London
filming on a Saturday who's actually got
the photo of the crowd see you st.
Tommy's flip-flops I don't know I mean
party's not going know how to change a
mood I thought all the men were in
London today all the lads all the lads
all the football yes I quote don't call
this on a patriot yeah if you're not
going to be there this side it's a very
good point all that makes it seem like I
come against the black community because
I'm totally not and that's not because
of any Fritz because I have a [__]
that's you it's not a first it's because
principally that's not who I am
so the first things first yeah it's not
because he's had threats against that
he's now coming out and saying he's not
against a black community this is his
own decision yes he's come up with all
these views on his own after his
previous video where he came out with
views that might not have pleased
everyone now I hope you understand when
you're watching this and I've said I'm
gonna be in London to defend the war
memorial yeah he is now making in front
of his own words like this he's doing a
job for us more presently in London now
and many of the young black lads are
gonna go are going because they think
they're defending the black community
from people who are coming to attack him
because that's how it's gone out I've
seen how a 20-second clip it's a
20-second clip let's run it with him
bashing black lives matter yeah not only
was it a 20 second clicked on me I'm
pretty sure it was about a five-minute
video in which you just continually went
on about black lives matter and how all
the protests are wrong and how
everything that they were doing down
there was a problem and then you went
for two of the biggest faces in the
movement and said how they should be
ashamed of it I must have got the wrong
end of the stick that's what I got from
that video but maybe I meant you've
completely misread him yeah Tommy
Robinson's heart is always in the right
place so when I first watch his video I
had a thought of our friend believing
Bruce great guys he often talks about
they
slaying psychology yeah the body
language that we give off when we're
talking normally yeah now as you'll see
in the first video from Tommy the one
thing he never did was touch his nose he
didn't touch his nose a lot it's not
something he does normally now when he
talks about how he doesn't want to be a
part of racial tensions I noticed right
around this moment just look at his nose
I'm just gonna look it it's not touching
the face three four yeah right now we
have enough it in the [__] corner
make ya cerebellum would be all over the
place it's the first time I watch that I
was lying [__] right yeah you're
absolutely layer we can't say where the
Tommy Robinson is conclusively lying I
would say I don't think that Tommy
Robinson is lying all right he's in my
opinion then yeah he's not lying right
no I'm not gonna be in London on Sally
okay I'm not gonna be there
not because I tie even though their
names man with these little rappers and
that [__] putting things up yeah not
because of any of that all right so just
to be clear he started with not because
of the threats have been made on his
life not frightened of any of them ends
with all these that'll wrap us don't
even know your names I'm not threatened
by you fine don't worry about why
mention it just to be clear yeah he
definitely is not scared of the robbers
but here's the video that really brought
it home to me about what's going on in
America and in the UK we know a family
member related to this this is the the
uncle of Vidal Reilly who's on the
podcast before the father who gets taken
down in this video by the police is the
the dad of rectory - yeah who is a
member of the doubt spam yeah this is
just [__] awful
it's the trigger-happy attitude of some
of these cops to cite this is a sixty
odd year-old man you know you can see
the way he's just hit the deck there was
no danger there who didn't need at a
zoom you didn't need a renderer
surely that a man of that age if there's
any confrontation you can handle without
needing to potentially kill him which
that could have easily have done so this
is what excessive force is this is a
clear example of it I mean it just could
have killed him here's some footage
today of some Patriots
[Applause]
now I understand what tommy said last
week when he said how can the police let
protesters and people who are there push
the [__] police around British
Patriots would have more respect for the
police let's just watch these clips very
respectful as you can see there see what
he meant by football fans now I'm as
excited for the Premier League returning
as anymore absolutely yeah I mean yeah
it's torn you push the police around for
what should click off Wednesday night if
you're a true patriot you watch the
kickoff confusing thing about this is
see these guys are here to defend the
Churchill Monument absolutely Churchill
what the man who fought against the
Nazis yeah yeah I'm not sure I think
they're probably using them fans you
idolize Alan Shearer fair fair it's
gotta be directly in there silly sod I
couldn't imagine that someone who
supports Winston Churchill a man who
fought against the Nazis in the Second
World War and calls himself a patriot
for Britain a clearly non Nazi country
would think and Nazi salute was
appropriate maybe they're just fans of
Superman then what the remove it we
ought well do we let's go to a lot of
people who probably feel a lot of white
guilt now someone who is a massive
phenomenon and I don't mean figuratively
speaking in the 90s its Oprah I see in
this clip and I thought was quite
interesting because we talked recently
on the show about how racism to some
people feels like something from 200 300
years ago slavery was not that long ago
in America and the the Leafs held by the
people who owned slaves was passed down
generation to generation and you can see
in this clip 1987 this is like our
parents era yeah but in a place in
America Oprah goes there asks why they
don't want black people in the town tell
me where did the people who can't come
from who were shouting
[__] go home they came from where yes
man they came from my name's Frank
Shirley I'm the head of the committee to
keep Forsyth and Dawson County
why just be clear this guy is about 25
although he dresses like he's about 55
from the 1800s he will still be around
now this guy will have kids now he will
have passed his views down no doubt to
those kids so let's see what he says
okay the news media is covered up there
were thousands of white people that came
out to join our white people's
protesters largest white people's
protest against communism and
race-mixing in the last 30 years hey
Mark hey Brian I just anti-black you're
also anti
I'm opposed to communism race-mixing and
low morals and homosexuals are of low
morals in my opinion couldn't agree more
instead of a Venn diagram I'd say a lot
of these guys cross over it's
interesting to see how someone so
blatant about it because now you get
people certain people out there who
they're very clever with how they choose
their words but you can tell but they
just don't come right over them this guy
just had no she believed that people of
other races have the right to live here
they have the right to live wherever
they want to but we have the right to
choose if we want a white community also
that's why we moved here
I believe what she's saying is you can
live anywhere just it's not here yeah no
credit to over a buck in the day by the
way because we sort of she was kind of
lost on our generation she was before
our time but when I watch this I was
like wow you're a black woman and a
roomful of people who probably look in
here yeah you're showing complete calm
you're making everyone feel relaxed and
you're getting them to be themselves and
that's the way that she's getting this
story out of them you know I'd credit
what a [__] way to interview people I
[Music]
mean it looks amazing I love it yeah I
love me with all this job spoil it I
love it
listen as an influencer perfectly open
to receiving a package from Playstation
when this launch is I love it we've done
the black box for quite some time both
consoles have been just basic black
boxes yeah I like the bit of style I
love the control controller looks
amazing yeah it does look like a bit of
a white folder with something inside of
it we get it so some some other things
have also have white things on the side
yeah but I think that this has got a bit
more style than the Xbox the Xbox is
really basic this year they are two very
different approaches much like a
building where is this it flows it is a
it's kind of beautiful so these are the
games
can't tell again if this is the old oven
you but see all right I'll have to say
looking back on a lot of this ps4 a
little bit of a letter the games I mean
love PlayStation but the games were a
bit nothing to find that error era of
console video when I look back at that
era I'm not gonna go that was a
generation defining moment PlayStation 2
generation define you just to be clear
Grand Theft Auto 5 was a PlayStation 3
game that they've ported to ps4 so that
we can't put that as the the game of the
console thank God they weren't reporting
it to PS 5 they'll be just releasing a
brand new GT I'm looking for a lot yeah
and here comes the man who's going to
introduce you to PlayStation 5 who is
this man leading us into the next
generation it was great
to kick today off with a look back at
just some of the seminal moments of the
last 25 years
why don't they hire enough to feel I
don't quite understand because this guy
looks like he was in a failed eighties
band I think this is the moment where
you go and now we've got an ambassador
for PlayStation here is idris elba some
sort of some athlete a musician someone
cool LeBron James you know someone
really cool right now no disrespect in
your mind
I'm sure he's built the company up but
even as name does inspire an erection
does it although if Jim Ryan was a
character in Call of Duty you go Captain
Jim Ryan ready to go in that's cool
big cruncher is my father in the past
stars grudges more - was one of my
favorites Gran Turismo 2 is a classic
wasn't it a sovereign pros oh yeah what
I'm noticing is that the graphic jump
from ps4 appears 5 in that is it's not a
huge job like it wasn't the passport
like the amount of [__] going on on
camera at one time is like huge it's
looks like hit map
[Music]
oh this looks sick but our Lord does
that look that different from PS 40
that's what I'm saying I think what
we'll find is on on YouTube some of
these might not look as shockingly
better but they in person when we
finally play them it'll be like IRL know
all the little games are sweet isn't it
you'll be able to entertain your kids
for hours destruction it says look
amazing that reminds me they really need
to make a new rocket League if you're
watching could you sort of don't [__]
around with the mechanics of the games
make better-looking cause more
customization bad graphics right I'll be
happy if you can have it so you can
render Brian inside the car that would
be ideal make a true Geordi ha your
little head just not my hair though
little set of wheels just I just want my
logo on the car this is I'm Williamson
the next big thing in basketball boom
he's gonna be a superstar he already is
how insane did that look I would like to
see more gameplay yeah we already know
the gameplays good thanks to Kay and
what better way to bridge your past in
our future than with a game that's
graced every PlayStation console Grand
Theft Auto come on here we go six and
we're thrilled to open today with the
news that that partnership will continue
with PlayStation 4 my god yes it's time
Brian to see what GTA 6 looks like why
did I move here I guess it was the
weather or the bad thing the magic that
says fine what's going on
this is remastered
Grand Theft Auto 5.1 expanded and
enhanced but not new right okay so you
mean to tell me
Grand Theft Auto came up in 2013 and I'm
gonna have to wait until 2021
for the same [__] game to come out
again we've not had a new Grand Theft
Auto up in what will be eight years
eight [__] years just to be clear
Grand Theft Auto 5 was out on the
PlayStation 3 the PlayStation 4 and now
the place is rife with no new Grand
Theft Auto in the entire [__] time
how lazy can you get but I think this is
just a big switcheroo what they're doing
is they think the people who really love
Grand Theft Auto will buy a PlayStation
5 and grand theft auto 5 remastered what
they will find when they put the disc
into the console is it's actually grand
theft auto 6 that's right Brian the
people who were really dedicated and
really loved the game deserve it you
weren't murdered redemption was alright
was fun is incredible the most terrible
they count the horse how many times are
we gonna have to have a little faith
like it was bad writing but I'll let it
go eight [__] years without a new
iteration of the game I know it's a
moneymaker
it's hard to make a grant I thought of
how [__] long do we need to make way
for a new one honestly [__] this [__]
longer than eight years I hope there's a
new metal gear on that is Grand Theft
Auto 5 an exciting new biome yes on
PlayStation expanded and enhanced so
sometimes it'll look a bit better look
as much as my demands
just quickly FIFA sort the gameplay out
because I've seen milk turn quicker than
those players and the the column key
movement is just a joke
I'll be happy with that I want a new
FIFA just just sort the game broke
because the last one was terrible
remake a rocket League just keep the
mechanics great mechanics out cause all
the customization oh yes a new Metal
Gear Brian ironically I'd be happy with
the Metal Gear 1 reiteration right do
that again yeah you forgot about it I'm
glad that I've thought of 6 yeah that's
all whereas all a musket yeah I'm just
gonna have my lunch now right that was
true news subscribe like the video will
see us there